[Music]
all right let's go
to one more call let's go to carol in
omaha carol what's going on
well i'm glad to be talking to you and
that last call was uh
pretty close to home so but on a
different subject so anyway
i am a widow i got four grown four grown
children a possible grandkids
and until recently i kind of thought
i had raised all my children especially
with
um really solid values okay and i've
always felt like those 25 years of being
mostly a stay-at-home mom were
you know me living my true purpose in
life
and through the years i've uh you know
they might
as they were growing and declaring
themselves adults i
have been given many lessons on how to
let my grown children and then my young
adult grandchildren
make their own decisions as adults it's
not easy but
but one new development is just really
kind of just
breaking my heart on a lot of levels
so here goes um one of my sons and his
wife have recently discovered a
lucrative
way of making a living that involves
gathering
fans of her online photos
uh fans only only fans
yeah okay i have no idea i'm not asking
those questions i don't know
they just told me they told me they were
probably not the kinds of
photos that i need to see and i
don't want to put them in an album and
show them to my mom and say here break
on your grandchildren
why hey why did they tell you this how'd
this come up over pancakes
like hey mom by the way i opened a
so only fans is a site that
like stay-at-home moms or anybody can
use but yeah
it's it's uh this wouldn't even tell
people what it is in case they look it
up well
i mean it's it's it's common knowledge
for
those younger than you and me yeah yeah
um
anyway it came up because um
she was able to i mean she's earning a
lot of money
they are earning a lot of money and he's
in you know i mean
they are in it together they're making
it their business and she she quit her
job that's how it came up
and they were suddenly not pinched for
money and
so anyway okay so
there's hey mom guess what
i still bro i don't know um that's
beside the point yeah well we can
we can go back to that if we need to no
i'm good on that
so how can i help okay so
you're always talking about people
needing relationships and community and
stuff and
this one has me how do i build a
community of friends
when this is part of what i
really need to need friendships for whoa
this one's
it's i mean i was really proud
of raising my kids i was really proud of
myself as a mom probably too proud
hey carol carol kill carol carol
you didn't fail oh yeah
carol carol you didn't screw up
you didn't fail
that one's carol
you didn't fail
well i can't really say i feel like i've
succeeded
carol you didn't fail
success of raising your kids is
not hinge on the fact that they're going
to make only great decisions for the
rest of their lives
your time at home with them wasn't
wasted
you stepping in the gap when your
husband passed away
all of that energy and tears and
exhaustion and late nights
was not wasted you didn't fail
they're making decisions that you don't
like
but you and you didn't blow it
there's not something you could have
gone back and and
altered or twisted or changed that would
have shifted this outcome
so you gotta exhale
and drop your shoulders on that one
when you go back and blame yourself what
that does
is it allows you an illusion of control
that you had any control over the way
your
son or daughter or daughter-in-law
chooses to live their life in the first
place
and sometimes that lack of control is
scarier
than blaming myself for failing
and so i need if nothing else i'll give
you my thoughts on
your daughter and daughter-in-law and
your son but
nothing else you didn't fail you loved
the crap out of that kid
all four of them
that is very true and i still do love
them of course you do i love my
grandkids i love
you know i love my my in-laws i mean
and listen because you're your son
and daughter-in-law let's just stick
with your son okay
because your son is making different
um value choices than you
yeah morally moral choices in you um
doesn't mean you didn't raise him with
values
that's not what that means true it
doesn't mean
any of this is an indictment on you
at all so
then you fast forward and say i don't
like
the idea of my son and his wife
running a pornography business out of
their house that makes
me as their mom a little bit weirded out
i'm uncomfortable with that that makes
me angry that makes me frustrated that
makes me want to go
hit my son upside the head with a fly
swatter whatever the thing is
right so when i get
faced with those moments number one i
always go back
to like you mentioned relationship who
can i sit down and say this
really stinks who can i say that with
and it sounds like you're embarrassed to
tell your friends
that your son's doing this and here's
the thing if you have friendships
that you are embarrassed to be fully you
in they're not real friendships
they're pretend ships i just made that
word up i should i should i should
coin that i just made that up it's a
pretend ship it's not real yeah
it's got a it's got a ring to it i like
it i'm gonna make a t-shirt
if you can't call your friend and say
hey i
i'm seeing the universal now oh my gosh
i cheated on my husband
we gotta talk now if you can't call your
friend up and tell them that they're not
your friend
that doesn't mean your friend's gonna
sit down and go what are you doing
you're an idiot you [ __ ] you
that's what friends should be doing and
holding each other accountable but you
gotta be able to tell your friends the
good stuff
and the bad stuff not just the pretend
stuff
and my guess is you've got friends that
would hear this
and weep with you and be sad with you
and be broken-hearted with you
and they would tell you oh yeah well my
son did x
my son-in-law i mean my daughter-in-law
did why
you'd probably find some community you
didn't even know you had
and then the other thing is have you sat
down to talk to your son and said this
breaks my heart
um i've i've talked to him some but
i haven't actually been that
straightforward
okay so there's a moment where you're
gonna have to decide
the or what
right so let's pretend that your son
comes and you all have a conversation
and you say
honey i just need you to know this
breaks my heart
that you and your wife have chosen this
is the way y'all are going to make money
this breaks my heart um
i raised you to keep your sexuality
private between you and
and your spouse and y'all are
putting it out for the world to see and
again i'm just assuming that's what's
going on here right um yeah and it
breaks my heart
and then here's the or what so is it
going to be
so until you all take that sight down
you're not welcome at my home
i don't want you at family gatherings i
don't want you at thanksgiving i don't
want you at christmas i don't want to
see her face
is that or what or is he or what this
breaks my heart
and i don't talk about it anymore and
if i ever look sad it's because of that
but i love you guys
it's y'all's life to live and
um i'll be here now when y'all are
making a bunch of money and i'll be here
now when this thing goes
off the rails someday like those are the
two or what's right
and it helps to know up front because
what i see parents do
is they get in these conversations and
it gets loud and it gets emotional and
gets vulnerable
and then they say something they can't
take back yeah
no i mean i mean we've
we've been through enough conversations
that i didn't like to have
that it definitely is the latter of the
two i mean it's
the one of my is one of my questions
um you know is like how do you
talk to the grandkid i mean they've got
two little kids
preschoolers you don't that's not your
story to tell
okay i mean that's yeah i agree
if those kids if those kids i mean
you talk to your parents right it's
think about something more benign like
you don't
well that could be equally that's just
not your story to tell your job
your job is to love those kids sideways
and forwards and ups and downs like
you spoil the snot out of those kids
right that's your job
yep okay and if they ask you hard
questions
like hey we walked in and there's a
there's a photography studio i wonder
what's happening
that's you tell your son hey you're
you're my grandkids are asking questions
you're probably gonna need to have a car
hard conversations about what mommy does
for a living and i if your son called me
i would tell him
do not lie to your kids right
and so that's i mean he wants to call me
he's welcome too but
that's not that's not your job okay
that helps yeah all right
what else well i appreciate this what
else
how about this carol i i have to know
what is your or what
um can you call both of them
and just and have a face to face with
them
yeah and just say i love you guys
y'all are always welcome in my home if
and
if you're a real gangster grandma you
could say and i'm gonna make fun of
y'all all the time
that's how i handle sadness i like that
one that's how i see it
i was wondering if i if i could push you
know like kevin some
family counseling on the issue or so i
mean we've never we've never been a
family that really goes to counseling
that much
but well hardly ever i i don't
i think again if if they don't see this
as a family problem to solve
you're inviting them into your
boundaries you're inviting them into
your heartbreak
they're not heartbroken they called
their mom and told them
right now if you want to be super
gangster in person
go to the site go to the site and be
like yeah those pictures aren't great
but carol don't do that that'd be awful
for everybody don't do that but
you know what i'm saying i don't want to
have that in my head that's a you're a
wise wise
wise woman but
but here's the thing you can't control
it
and so what that means is you need to
get a friend or two in your life you can
be honest with invite them over make it
a whole thing
and just say i don't need you to fix
nothing i just need you to tell you i'm
heartbroken because my son
and his wife are making some decisions
that break my heart
okay and you're gonna feel powerless and
you have
solved every problem known to man for
the last 20 years
and you can't solve this one
yeah that's part of
what you learn to live with that's right
that's right
and then yeah that hey that's the best
noise
right and you got to make that noise in
the presence of somebody else who will
still love you
right and i want to say it again i'll
say it again i'll say it again
this is not your fault
they made choices adult grown-up choices
they got two little kids
and they're making adult grown-up
choices
and then now you get to make adult
grown-up choices
be thoughtful understand what your or
what is going to be
control what you can control and get
around people that care about you to let
you be fully you
and it will still love you that will be
fully you
and will laugh with you and cry with you
and be angry with you and
make that noise with you
and then love the snot out of those
grandkids and you let their moms and
dads have those hard conversations
that's not your job
but i think you need to have a open
direct conversation with them because
it's going to haunt you until you do and
one out of love
one out of not resignation and anger
the one that just says
man you're awesome carol thank you for
being a mom that stepped in the gap
being a single mom is
oh god almighty you raised four good
ones tough